But what if you want to actually know
what's going on inside human brains?
And presuming, presuming these
are people you actually like.
So how would you measure what's
going on in their brain?
Well, you're not going to stick
electrodes in their brain.
What you're going to do
is something called fMRI.
Okay, or
a functional magnetic resonance imaging.
So many of you probably have had an MRI,
or
an MRI uses strong magnetic fields to
sort of mess around with electrons in
order to be able to get
differential density measurements.
Well, you can do something cool also.
You can use a dye contrast that
the magnetic fields perturb
differently depending upon how much
oxygen is in that part of the the blood.
So, just like we did before with that
experiment with the monkeys where you
injected, sort of, that radioactive
isotope connect the oxygen.
Now what we can do is we can have you
have die contrast, go into an fMRI,
have you look at things, and see what
parts of your brain are lighting up.
All right?
So here's an example, sort of
notionally of an fMRI activation, so
this is of course obviously a
reconstruction based on the density, and
here you can see the activity
that's being done.
This is a three dimensional
reconstruction.
This is what a slice would
actually look like, right?
This is a single activation slice.
And these colors are different levels
of activation compared against a,
a background activation.
So one of the areas that people were
studying a lot, and arguing about was,
was there a part of the brain that
seemed very responsive to faces, okay?
And it's called the fusiform face area,
and
it's a little bit controversial
as to whether, or
not something really responds to just
faces, or other sorts of patterns.
This is a paper recently 2004, actually
Nancy Kanwisher, last author there,
was a graduate student,
when I was, same department, and
she does great work on
understanding physiology.
And, and these, this paper's one of the,
well known papers, Grill-Spector et al.
And they're just focusing on this area,
this FAA, fusiform face area,
in terms of understanding
where faces light things up.
One of the reasons for looking at faces
is that there's been a long history of
sort of faces being special in,
in human vision.
So there's examples that very,
very early on in an infant's life
they have a preference, and they do
test called preferential looking,
if you put something up does
the infant tend to look this way, okay?
So the, the,
the experimenter holds something.
The experimenter doesn't know whether
it's a picture of actually a face,
something blank like this, or something
that has the face pieces on it.
All the experimenter does is he,
he or she holds something up, and
he just says, yep,
I think he looked this way.
Yep.
Nope.
And the question is do you
tend to get the looking more
when you actually put
up a picture of face?
And the answer is,
says here er, early minute,
very early in life there seems
to be a preference for faces.
Likewise there were responses
of various other things,
responding to, this is a cell recording,
that when shown faces, responds, and
when shown these other things,
fruits, hands, et cetera, don't.
Likewise, there are measurements
using this fMRI
of areas that respond to faces.
And so, this is another paper,
another picture from that same
paper I showed you before.
And you'll see here that
they've got different
object types that they're showing,
and the idea is that different parts.
See, so you see this area here that
lights up really well with faces,
and doesn't here, here,
here, here, or there?
And the idea is that these
are other objects that,
sort of, took the same,
amount of location, and intensity, and
et cetera, but
only lit up when the faces were there.
So it was an example of understanding
a part of the brain doing a particular
process.